The building is ours. One way out! One way out! One way out!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Star Wars andor episode 10 video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs and references we'll
break it all down it was probably one of the best
episodes of the series so far if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes and careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs and WTF moments
starting with the episode title it was called
one way out which is a reference to their big
prison break because there's only one way out of
the Imperial prison and that's why Kino Loy kept
repeating that line of dialogue one way out it's
also meant to be a reference to Luthen's speech
at the end of the episode like it's meant to be
a parallel for that when he's talking about what
he's sacrificed for the Rebellion with Lonnie the
ISB officer in the context of losing speech it's
meant to be the one way out is death like he's
saying he sacrificed everything he's basically
trying to say that there's no way out he's trapped
just like Lonnie is trapped you can't leave us
we've invested too much time in you when Luthen
references his equation from 15 years ago that 15
years puts it right during the middle of Revenge
of the Sith when the emperor was creating the m
empire order 66 was going down he realized that
he wasn't going to get out of this alive like he's
going to die and if you think about it he's not
mentioned at all in the Canon during the events
of Rogue one or later in the timeline I think the
reason for that early theory is because he does
wind up dying while creating the Rebellion like
he will be successful like the Rebellion will come
together formally as a large fighting force but he
will die in the process so it was sort of like a
rallying cry for the prison break like it's really
happy moment for them like yeah we're getting out
of here but also kind of a sad tragic moment for
Luthen like oh we're getting out of here but the
only way we're getting out one way out is death
the actual opening scene is the guards at the
prison in the Medtech taking ooloff's body out
but taking it through the work room so that all
the other prisoners have to see it they decide
to make their big prison break and even though
it seems like it takes Kino Loy's character a
little while to come around like Andy Serkis'
character eventually does tell them very succinct
we're never getting out of here you're all
gonna die either on this level or when you get
transferred to another one so there is only one
way out for us Andy Serkis also did a couple
interviews was talking about his character's
backstory because they don't give you a whole
lot of details about his backstory in the actual
series he says he kind of came up with one himself
he said that he used to be a merchant character
who spoke out against the empire and that's what
got him thrown in prison the first time then Wally
was in prison he sort of tucked his tail between
his legs thinking that doing everything that they
asked at the Empire the guard's ass will get him
out quicker obviously that not being the case the
other really interesting thing at the beginning of
the episode here when they're first deciding like
oh yeah we're definitely going to get out of here
is Andor questioning what the Empire is actually
having them build at the prison there like what
are they actually having us make and I think the
best theory about that is that these parts are
actually for the Death Star itself and they've
been having him create the weapon that will
eventually destroy him that will kill him during
Rogue one I think that flows with the themes of
the actual series like they're basically using the
people against themselves that's why the Empire is
so Insidious then at the ISB dead Resorts briefing
them on the rebel Heist that they're trying to
pull on the rebel group because they want to
catch them in the act and they're trying to make
it look like this rebel pilot died by accident
when she mentions the ship caffreen rescue Salvage
caprine is actually the base that Andor is at at
the beginning of the Rogue one movie the actual
Rebel group that they're trying to catch is led
by Anto Krieger the person that Luthen wanted Saw
Gerrera to work with meaning that if they would be
successful if he hadn't found out about it during
the episode they would have wound up catching saw
Guerrero's group as well but obviously this is
all meant to set up the big turn at the end of
the episode when we find out what's going on with
Lonnie's character we briefly go back to ferrics
for a hot minute just to check in with Sinta who's
been watching andor's home waiting for him to show
up gonna get there eventually but obviously we
have to break out of prison first so just gonna
be a hot second before he makes it back but I
think this is just meant to remind us that oh we
are coming back to ferrics before the end of the
season like they'll end the season on ferricks we
meet that pseudo-crime boss Davo Sculdin, tay
kolma wanted Man mothma to borrow money from
to hide her previous donations to the rebels his
whole story about visiting Coruscant 30 years ago
would have put him there well before the events of
phantom menace in the earlier very early days of
Palpatine Senate run he actually became senator
in the days before Chancellor valorum took over
the Senate when he joined the Senate the Supreme
Chancellor was named score kalpana it was actually
his master Darth Plagueis who arranged for him to
become the senator from Naboo that position also
gave him control over like 36 other worlds inside
a single sector so he had a lot of political power
when he started out and it was all part of this
long-term Sith plan to slowly take over the Galaxy
Darth Plagueis wanted to plant his apprentice
inside the Senate and then have him slowly create
connections so more descent just built his power
base then eventually do what you saw happen during
the events of the prequels you have to remember
though at a certain point Palpatine wound up
killing Darth Plagueis and becoming the sis Master
himself so at a certain point Plagueis plan became
Palpatine's plan we also learned Davo is from
Chandrila originally like mon Mothman her husband
and take hulma his whole speech about being rich
not having to listen to others opinions is just
to give you more of a Vibe of his character
like he's meant to be as slimy as possible
feel just like the other people who would cozy up
with Palpatine and just try to use power towards
their own ends they actually did a little bit
of this during the tales of the Jedi episodes
where you learn about a lot of corrupt Senators
during the events of the prequels or before the
events of the prequels technically the whole idea
is that even before Palpatine came along there was
a lot of corruption in the Senate which is why
it was so easy for him to take over the Senate
if you remember Mama's big concern in this at
least before their conversation was that she'd be
blackmailed for political favors it turns out that
was the least of her problems he wants his son to
become engaged to mon mothma's daughter because
according to their Customs they can get married
when they're 15 and they're almost 15. even though
she flat out tells him no as he leaves I think the
idea is that she does need the money to cover up
her Rebel transactions but I think that's where
luthin comes in because he has this giant pile
of money in because right after the scene we go
straight to Luthen's shop so they want you to be
thinking about Luthen and mon mothma's Association
I think they'll tie up that plot line by the end
of the season so we'll know for sure exactly how
she's going to wrap that up but like I said I
think it's going to have something to do with
lucan's Rebel money they stole from aldhani one
of the other interesting details during their
conversation too is that you notice that mon
mothma refuses to look him in the eye and she
gets really pissed off when she finds out about
her husband's association with him like oh I hang
out with your husband all the time oh I bet you do
they make it sound like she actually kind of hates
her husband and the way that davo talks about
chandrilan marriage customs and the separation
between husband and wife makes it sound like they
live really separate lives and that's a regular
thing in the history of their people in the way
that in medieval times in real life you'd have a
lot of political marriages and husband and wife
wouldn't actually be in love with each other so
oftentimes there'd be a lot of infidelity in the
marriage and usually was tolerated as long as it
was kept off the radar so to speak like when you
start having scandals public starts finding out
about it that's when people start getting stabbed
and getting their heads chopped off so he's just
making it sound like Mon mothma and her husband
just don't know exactly what each other are doing
during the day when we go to Luthen's shop it
seems like they've only moved around a couple
of the artifacts and easter eggs behind him
these giant horns here seem like they're the
same types of horns from Mas Amedda's race he's
a chagrigan in the rounded helmet that he scans
is the one that Padme wears during the prequels
the one next to it I think we've all agreed is
a wookie battle helmet I've already talked about
a lot of the easter eggs in the back of the shop
too like he has a duplicate Starkiller armor
the giant box on the right seems like a Jedi
holocron but it's really big for a Jedi holocron
usually a little bit smaller if you remember a
couple episodes ago too on the left side on this
wall here we actually saw an Indiana Jones easter
egg these are the stones from Temple of Doom in
real life lucasfilm just announced that they're
actually working on an Indiana Jones TV show for
Disney plus but I don't know what it's going to
be about or if it'll be like a continuation of
the young Indiana Jones chronicles presumably
we'll see it in a couple years so we'll find out
pretty soon what it's about then we get our big
prison break this is one of my favorite parts
of the episode this and Luther's scene at the
end of the episode their first countermeasure to
short out the floor security system that shocks
the bulkheads is it just flood the floor when they
start attacking the guards and climbing out they
do show you that a couple of them do die in the
process like this isn't a completely bloodless
escape the minute they head up the stairs and
they show you how far up it is just made me
think of that scene from Avengers end game with
the Hulk the Hulk versus stairs so many stairs
inside the control room before they take it over
the guard's next reactionary measure is to fry a
bunch of the levels like they fry that entire
level before to keep the prisoners quiet but
this time with the prison break they're like okay
we'll shut down a bunch of the levels when they
do take over the control room andor repeats
their orders back to the guards on program
and Kino Loy gives this big rousing Escape speech
basically to tell them to get the hell out one way
out repeating that line of dialogue the title of
the episode I believe it was meant to be about 5
000 total prisoners in that particular prison
his whole speech is also meant to be a metaphor
for the Rebellion just in general the whole idea
that it's better that they die trying to escape
rather than comply with the Empire they're sort
of the same idea with luthan's character like he
is prepared to die he knows he is going to die in
the act of rebelling against the empire but that's
better than doing nothing earlier this season
Andor also made a couple references to the guards
being relatively weak and poorly equipped most of
the ones who aren't already dead are hiding behind
this locked door waiting for everyone to escape
before they come out just sort of paying that off
like oh yeah they are pretty sucky guards Kino
Loy not being able to swim seems kind of like a
tragic moment like they don't show you what winds
up happening to him because you only see Andor and
melshi running away at the end of the episode
so you're like what happened to the rest of the
prisoners that escaped did they all die did some
of them get away I think they just want to leave
you wondering what eventually happens to Andy
circus's character like he could still be alive
or he could have died in the attempt he could have
just drowned while they were trying to swim away
but I think part of the idea is that a number of
these people who do Escape will eventually wind
up joining the rebellion and just because they
only show us Andor and his friend at the end of
the episode doesn't mean that they're the only two
that wound up escaping but a bunch of these others
swimming away probably did subsequently die during
their attempt and if you think it's weird that
someone like Kino Loy wouldn't be able to swim
even in real life like in First World countries
there are a lot of adults who still cannot swim
if you can believe it surprisingly there are a lot
of drowning deaths every single year around the
world then probably the other biggest reveal of
the episode is that dedra's co-worker her fellow
supervisor is part of the Rebellion or has been an
informant working with them from inside the belly
of the Beast so to speak the whole time and just
to be clear he is meant to be the same rank as
Dedra so he has the same level of authority just
over a different part of the Galaxy he was the
supervisor in the previous episode who alerted
them to increased activity near scarif which is
meant to be a reference to the events of Rogue one
and the Death Star like activity is increasing
towards that part of the system because of
everything the ISB is doing trying to create the
Death Star the place where they go to meet is in
coruscant's lower levels where all the Shady stuff
all the criminal activity gets done remember that
Coruscant is a planet-wide city that just built on
top of older City and as the city gets bigger they
just continue building on top of the previous
City like all the wealthiest people live on the
top and all the poor people live underneath so you
have thousands and thousands of years of City just
built on top of older City they explored some of
this during the Clone Wars like Ahsoka travels way
way down to the lower levels they do a good job
of visual storytelling during this too with a
lot of his actions like he grabs for the calm
knowing that it would be there without having
to look for it meaning that they've done this
before but Luther says it's been about a year
since they've actually met with each other the
way they explain their backstory is that he's
been working with luthin helping the rebellion
and they've kind of been informing each other
like Luthen feeds him information which he uses
to advance his rank inside the ISB for the past
six years and he's been tipping off Luthen helping
the Rebellion along the way the whole thing with
lutherly threatening the life of his newborn
daughter is also meant to let you know that
he's not helping the rebels completely willingly
and he's trying to continue to ensure his loyalty
like oh by the way you have that daughter we
want to do everything we can to make sure she
has a wonderful life and a wonderful father the
whole idea with this is just to show you that
the rebels do things that are just as shady and
bad as the Empire short of full-blown genocide
like they do with the Death Star later like as
bad as the rebels are and they are doing things
that are really bad especially Luthen all this
collateral damage that he's totally fine with
the Empire is still worse the reason Luthen lies
about their involvement in the heist on aldani
like he denies that he was connected to it I think
it's him hedging his bets in case Lonnie winds up
being found out and interrogated by Dedra so that
it doesn't wind up confirming her suspicions if
he is caught and that's also why he's willing to
sacrifice Anto Kreeger it's only 50 men they're
worth it we don't want to tip off the Empire
we want things to continue as usual also when
Luthen says that he's doing all this for Lonnie
for him it's just to psychologically manipulate
him as an informant to keep him loyal to the
cause keeping him wrapped around his finger so
to speak because I think if Lonnie had protested
too much Luthen would have killed him unless they
do a good job of foreshadowing all this stuff
during their conversation Luthen telling him
about sacrifice and there being no way out for
either of them and it being kind of a parallel
for Kino Loy's statement one way out but for them
it's a tragic statement and it means that they'll
both probably wind up dying in the cause the one
way out will be them dying Luthen's whole speech
here at the end of the episode also probably
one of my favorite speeches in all of Star Wars
recently we'll see if they topped this during
the Mandalorian season 3. like there's been a
lot of great Mandalorian episodes but I feel like
Andor has really taken at next level with some of
the character dynamics and like I said when he
talks about the 15 years ago the equation that
he wrote that's meant to be during the events of
Revenge of the Sith when that was all going down
when he also references sharing his hopes and
dreams with ghosts I think that's him saying in
so many words that his loved ones died like his
family died and that's one of the things that
helped Inspire him to create the rebellion and
we see Andor and the other future Rebel Melshi,
continuing to escape on foot and obviously
I think the reason why they showed us farex
briefly during the episode is to just let you
know that Andor will come back to pharynx and
that's what we're going to end the last couple
of episodes if there are any other easter eggs
and references that you spotted in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
down below in the comments and let me know do
you think the Kino Loy wound up surviving their
escape attempt my full episode 11 video will
post next week after they release it there's
a bunch of stuff happening this week too my
black panther will come a forever post credit
scene video and full breakdown in easter eggs
for the entire movie will post later this week
be sure to go see the movie as soon as possible
everyone click here for my review of the movie
and click here for my other post-credits scene
video I'll update the link as soon as I post
that video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!